well it's always a little hard to know  exactly how long it takes me to write  something because I'm constantly writing  and then I don't know what pieces will  become something but what I do know is  that I I have a draft a very long draft  so at least at least a couple years so  you honed it down how long is a long  draft like  um that was about 350 pages  and I mean some of the scenes didn't go  anywhere it wasn't like it wasn't like  350 pages of something that was  narratively cohesive it was 350 pages of  stuff that then I  um kind of looked at and figured out  what felt essential and what felt like  the core of the story to me yeah  um and it's some I don't really decide  what a core of a story is before I write  I I write to figure out what the story  is and  and I think that the characters end up  talking to you and telling you what they  want to be doing and what what is  important to them